the nation's biggest thanks made a
dramatic move today to rescue a smaller
bank and head off a potential crisis a
big move now some of the world's largest
banks have given First Republic Bank a
billion dollar bailout to keep it from
collapsing california-based First
Republic Bank was given a 30 billion
dollar Lifeline from 11 other banks in a
deal partly brokered by treasury
secretary Janet Yellen fewer money in
tonight after the collapse of those two
American Banks the rescue this evening a
group of American Banks now creating a
30 billion dollar rescue package to save
First Republic Bank
[Music]
running again another U.S bank went
under First Republic is the 14th largest
U.S bank yet they may be on the brink of
financial collapse four banks have hit
rock bottom in less than a week
silvergate Bank Silicon Valley Bank
Signature Bank Credit Suisse and now the
contagion has spread to one of America's
biggest Regional Banks despite being a
mid-sized Bank First Republic caters to
the same wealthy clientele as Silicon
Valley bank now it's looking like they
might end up sharing a little more than
just clients since the failure of
Silicon Valley Bank First Republic has
lost a whopping 70 of its market value
and just like all these other Banks the
guys in charge knew what was coming long
before it happened on March 6th two days
before the banking sector crisis the
bank's Chief risk officer sold Company
stock and since the beginning of the
year insiders have sold almost 12
million dollars in Company stock
including executive chairman James
Herbert II who has sold 45 million
dollars worth of shares
they all knew what was coming but what
they didn't know was just how far the
government would go to bail out their
rich clients with taxpayer money so they
sold their stocks just in case they went
the same way as sbv the bank's president
of private Wealth Management Robert
Thornton made the largest sale of the
year on January 18th dropping 73 of his
shares totaling 3.5 million dollars
before that he hadn't traded since 2021.
stay dangerous and let's get into it
[Music]
to it
First Republic shares a lot of
similarities with Silicon Valley Bank
they had an overlapping client base they
both prioritized serving the extremely
wealthy and they also both had an
alarming amount of uninsured deposits
about 70 percent of its deposits are
uninsured above the median of 55 for
medium-sized Banks and the third highest
in the group after Silicon Valley Bank
and Signature Bank because of these
similarities it didn't take long for
people to start worrying First Republic
Bank was about to go the same way as
Silicon Valley Bank and since the only
smart thing to do when a bank goes under
is to get out shareholders started
selling stock at record rates before
First Republic Bank even had a chance to
make a public statement things went from
bad to worse since the failure of
Silicon Valley Bank First Republic has
lost more than 70 percent of its market
value its stock was plunging and after
Silicon Valley Bank everyone knew what
would happen if First Republic didn't
get bailed out fast luckily for First
Republic daddy government was right
there waiting to give them a handout the
plan for the rescue of First Republic
Bank First emerged on Tuesday during a
coordinated call between treasury
secretary Janet Yellen and Jerome H
Powell the chairman of the Federal
Reserve the mid-sized lender reached a
deal on Thursday to receive 30 billion
dollars in deposits from nearly a dozen
banks in an effort to ease investors
fears and stabilize the banking system
so a dozen big Banks and the FED got
together to bail out first Republic but
how did First Republic get here in the
first place
thank you since the start of 2023
there's been some seriously Shady stuff
happening at First Republic insiders at
the struggling Regional Bank First
Republic sold 11.8 million dollars in
the company's stock this year shortly
before its share price collapsed six
First Republic insiders sold 90
682 shares of the firm stock between
January 17th and March 6th at a share
price between 123 and 145 dollars they
include executive chairman James Herbert
CEO Michael Roffler head of credit David
Lichtman and banking Chief Michael
Selfridge those shares would be worth
just 3.1 million dollars at first
Republic's Thursday share price of
34.35 none of the filings by Executives
were indicated to be under 10 b5-1 plans
essentially meaning none of them were
pre-scheduled sales basically this means
that executives were dumping their
shares as fast as they could because
they knew something big was about to go
down in fact the bank's Chief risk
officer sold stocks just days before
Silicon Valley Bank failed and set off
the crisis but that didn't matter just
like the banks before them that went
under First Republic was once again
deemed too big to fail and for the
biggest banks it was the perfect time to
consolidate power
the business of banking is completely
dependent on the masses believing that
the bank can pay them back even though
they do not have enough money on hand to
do so if there's even one tiny chip in
the armor it could trigger a bank run
and the thing is this applies to all
banks if the masses lose trust in One
Bank they'll start to question other
Banks too and withdraw their money so if
you're a banker you're kinda all in this
scheme together no matter how much you
hate your competitors if they collapse
you're probably gonna have to Fork the
bill if you don't want them taking you
down with them but if you do it right
you can turn this bailout into a massive
opportunity to consolidate power just
like what John Pierpont Morgan did
during the Panic of 1907 him and other
Bankers bailed out the entire stock
market and the banking system he
assembled the city's commercial and
Trust Company Banker put them in
separate rooms lock the front door and
kept the key in his pocket until he
could negotiate a deal at 4 30 a.m
Morgan finally bullied them into signing
an agreement it called for the Trust
Company Bankers to bail out their
brother Bankers who were struggling with
runs on their deposits when it was all
said and done and JP Morgan was called
in to testify before Congress he was
asked whether he commanded any power
over the economy he replied quote not
the slightest end quote and it looks
like the same thing is happening today
the 11 biggest banks in America knew
that by giving First Republic some money
they'd be showing everyone just how
strong and resilient America's banking
system was and if people believe the
banking system was okay they'd be less
likely to bring down other banks by
selling stock or withdrawing their money
in a press statement the bank said their
action quote reflects their confidence
in First Republic and in Banks of all
sizes end quote adding that quote
Regional mid-size and small banks are
critical to the health and functioning
of our financial system end quote First
Republic Bank officially got the
go-ahead to borrow a 30 billion dollar
Lifeline from some of the largest banks
in America this show of support by a
group of large Banks is most welcome and
demonstrates the resilience of the
banking system the treasury Department
enthusiastically said in a statement on
Thursday but just like the Panic of 1907
and the great financial crisis of 2008
we won't know the extent of all the
Shady stuff happening right now until
years later
[Music]
oh